not to even wait for white to play a4
here
but he probably wants to be able to play
b5 yeah that that's probably exactly
right yeah
because now if you allow bishop 7 all of
your previous play makes
king g5 g6 h7 but then we're losing the
f1 this is
okay it might be back to being
sort of objectively a draw no but what
is happening here
how do you how do you win can you say
queen e6 i mean the queen is shakesh
i mean the queen is i mean what is this
is ridiculous
and it's a draw i mean this isn't i mean
don't stop with this what what's
like come on what is the yeah queen
jacob is an immediate draw queen of five
is also an idiot draw sir
wow
[Laughter]
what angles does not look happy what
see if i'm cursing there yeah
or i assume it's cursing yeah i think
that's a safe bet
no i i don't see how you like avoid made
in four maiden four there like what's
what's
well you don't avoid mating forwards
yeah he just leaned he just leaned into
the
into the screen and and then out and
yeah the game the game appears to be
over
and magnus arms up in the air
cannot believe it swearing at the screen
disgusted with himself
spent five minutes on a move to play a
blunder
f1 we can actually take on h3 is this
the last moves of the tournament
this is it ladies and gentlemen
you can see hikaru arriving at
five stage number five of adapter um
yeah is there any threats against the
black king what was that did you see
that magnus is just very very upset with
him
this is a mouse sleep was it a muscle it
was such a strange move to make
i mean it looks like a mouse sleep no
because magnus was shaking his head like
what have i done like if he wanted to
play
he wanted to play luke d5 maybe yeah
this looks like a muslim
wow
ah because look g1 but what is it bishop
h5
f5 uh g6 the bishop is trapped jesus oh
wow
what a resource oh my god i don't think
black is winning with this material
distribution on the queen side but only
black can be better if this bishop good
that's a beautiful spot magnus just
so angry he he can't believe it
i mean can we just go back one move
because there was a chance of playing
look at f5 for black but it was made by
bishop e8 okay who has magnus missed
rook c1
let's check the camera it seems so right
this looks like he's missed it
oops oof he has missed it yeah yeah yeah
you can see his face
yeah wow
ah okay but it was i thought you had
king gonna sleep
maybe bishop f4
king h3 and you just go king f7 kingdom